[Music]
hello everyone
it is i national master caleb denby here
again
teaching the typically grand master's
choice tonight national masters choice
class
here on youtube uh and today i wanted to
walk you guys through a really fun
concept in chess
if you've been staying up to date on the
twitch stream
if you're a cable demi super fan
catching all of everything that i do
you may have seen me uh cover or at
least introduce
this topic before it's one of my
favorites in
chess it has less to do with
uh you know traditional end game
theory and game you know strategy
tactics things like that
and it's almost more like a logic puzzle
that's
buried within the rules of chess
and that topic of course is
corresponding squares
uh so what are corresponding squares
well to understand what they are
first we need to know what key squares
are and then we can actually
build from there so i've started with a
very very very simple
king and pawn position uh
that has been seen you know millions and
millions of times before
might be exaggerating but certainly a
lot and this of course
is well known to be a draw no matter
whose side it is
to to move in this case it is in fact
white to move
why is it a draw well because of course
the pawn gets pushed forward
everybody knows this and we end up with
the kings in a stalemate at the end of
the day
so the winning technique in these end
games is to actually to try to get the
king
in front of the pawns right if the king
goes
to a bad square we can get in front of
the pawn
and battle the king back using our king
and pawn together
eventually uh promoting the promoting
the pawn right we gain control of all
the squares
so many of you probably know the rule
that if you can get the king two squares
in front of the pawn
then you win the game that's a typical
rule
that we are taught in these end games as
for why that is
well if you get two squares in front of
the pawn
if your opponent tries to oppose your
king you can play the move e3
the enemy king has to step away and then
you can sort of gain ground
using the opposition and the idea of
corresponding squares
is linked around this idea
of the kings being very good at opposing
each other
like this you know you've heard the term
opposition but they do it from afar
and they do it in really really
interesting ways
and that is where corresponding squares
come in so
uh first and foremost what are the key
squares in the position
well those squares that we're taught if
we can reach with our king
they're always winning it turns out in
many many many end game positions you
can
find squares such as these where if you
can reach this square
with the king you do in fact just win
the game
in this end game these are those three
squares
why is e3 not a key square well of
course because if the king steps to e3
the enemy king can still step to e5
gaining the opposition and white cannot
get access
to any of the key squares if the king
steps elsewhere
we get on a key square and win the game
so now we know these are our three key
squares a key square being if we reach
this square
with our king then the game is over we
know we have a winning position
so in this case these are the three key
squares
and the corresponding squares are
actually going to be built
outwards from these key squares
so the first thing i want to talk about
is in fact this square
on e3 this square on e3
actually has a corresponding square on
the board also known
as sister squares whatever you want to
call it there's another square
on the board that is sort of linked to
e3
of course that square is in fact going
to be e5
right and this sort of makes sense we
know that if the white king steps to e3
the black king has to step to e5 and so
these squares are sort of tethered
together
in this manner right whenever the white
king steps to e3
the black king must step to e5 or else
black will lose
because white will get to the key
squares however
we want to build a slightly more general
idea of what corresponding squares are
than just this one position so let's
talk about it in a more general sense
so why are e3 and e5 linked
outside of this basic rule that we all
know as the opposition we don't want to
focus on just
opposition we want to focus on why are
these squares actually linked
and the reason is white is making three
threats
from e3 he threatens to step to f4 or
sorry d4
which would win the game because it's a
key square he threatens to step to e4
which is a key square and would win the
game and he threatens to step to f4
and because he threatens to step to each
of these squares
the corresponding squares on the board
have to
also threaten these three squares or
defend these three squares depending on
what you know terminology you want to
use
so black must also be attacking these
three squares or defending
and the only square on the board that
has this ability other than
e3 is the square e5 and so these two
are corresponding squares however there
are actually more corresponding squares
in this basic basic position that we can
talk about here for example
the square d3 actually has corresponding
squares on the board
uh which squares correspond to d3 well
in fact
it's only going to be d5
and at first glance this doesn't make
the most sense
right because d3 threatens to step to d4
and it threatens to step to e4
right so there are multiple squares
on the chessboard that black can step to
to defend both of these squares
number one is yes d5 which is sort of
the intuitive one
but why doesn't e5 also count as a
corresponding square to d3
well it's because white is actually
making a third thread
if white steps to d3 and black steps to
e5
intuitively many chess players already
know that the white king could step to
e3
to win the game but why is this so why
does this make sense
using our corresponding squares
technique well
it's because obviously intuitively we
know that
it wins because white gains the
opposition and then steps to a key
square
but in the theory of corresponding
squares it's because
uh whites is actually sorry if i get my
arrows
under control white is actually making
three threats
from the square on d3 yes he threatens
to step to these two squares
but he also threatens to step to e3
which corresponds to the square on e5
so in fact to be a true corresponding
square
to d3 black also has to have this
ability
yes to step to these two key squares but
also to step to the corresponding square
to e3 he has to be able to step on the
linked square
to e3 and that's why d5 is the only
corresponding square to d3 otherwise if
king d3
king e5 now all of a sudden king e3
and black will not have the ability to
step to the corresponding square
because he's already on it so he would
in fact have to step
off of the corresponding square and then
white can
invade uh of course
this idea holds true because in on f3
and
f5 because it's some very similar uh
symmetry
you know you can step to f4 e4 or e3
so black must also defend these two
squares and defend the corresponding
square
all right so that's about as basic as
king and pawn
and games uh can get and that's the most
basic form of the corresponding square
so i want to make sure
everybody watching right now is sort of
on board with
this basic uh basic idea
uh of the the corresponding squares that
we have in this position
e4 d4 f4 all key squares
e3 and e5 corresponding squares linked
squares
d3 only linked to d5 because it
also threatens to step to
uh step to e3 as well as these two
squares got some some cars honking some
horns always fun
uh okay if everybody's on board let's
move on
to a slightly more complex position
this one is obviously also very very
basic
you know most chess players will know
offhand this is of course a draw because
the black king is in front of the pawn
the white king is behind the pawn
but let's focus on it for just a moment
and see if we can build
the corresponding squares here
so first of all some
key squares obviously if white gets in
front of the pawn
anywhere over here we know that white
wins
the game so from
the key squares we want to build
outwards so let's start
with the square of e6
so what does e6 threaten to do
well e6 threatens to come to
d7 and threatens to come to e7 so what
corresponds with e6
e6 in e8 says uh chess king
so okay let's make it blue just because
i like blue
so e8 definitely corresponds to
e6 e6 are there any other
corresponding squares to e6
any other corresponding squares
do we think is e8 the only one
chess king was thinking d8 so is
d8 a corresponding square let's uh try
and figure it out
it definitely controls these two squares
so
c8 is not going to be a corresponding
square because e6 threatens these two
key squares that we were mentioning
and c8 only defends this one doesn't
defend e7
so c8 is out uh chess king says d8
is not so would you care to share your
thinking chess king why is d8 not a
corresponding square
f7 is uh you're gonna have to
use more words billy club uh obviously
f7 cannot correspond
itself to uh e6 because
it's illegal for both kings to be on
these squares if you mean
the king can come to f7 then that's a
different story
but also an incorrect one because if
king f7 came d7 and the pawn
would fall f7 is not
a key square
so i don't think maybe chess king is
typing up a a beautiful explanation
d8 is not because d7 wins
uh okay so let's take a look
let's say king c8 king e6
king d8 and yes so so d7
does win the game here which means that
d8 does not
correspond to e6 well
spotted okay so we have e6 and e8
as corresponding squares similarly now
we can build
the corresponding squares on the other
side i'm going to use
yellow uh c6 and c8
are corresponding squares ain't this a
draw
yes this is in fact a draw billy
uh we are starting simple and then
building
outwards to some very very complex
positions that we can hopefully solve
using corresponding squares so c6 and c8
are also going to be corresponding
squares just you know by virtue
of the symmetry in the position uh now
let's get rid of the key squares
for a moment what about the square on
d5 what corresponds
to d5 how can we build
a corresponding square to d5
how can we do this so chess king says d7
yeah this is sort of the obvious one
it takes the opposition
are there any other corresponding
squares to d5 and try to
try to use this corresponding squares
technique as well as
you know just from chess knowledge you
might be able to figure out what the
other one is but
it'll be helpful later on if we try to
build this using this technique rather
than just chest knowledge
any other corresponding squares
so in fact there is actually another
corresponding square
on d8 why does this square also
correspond
well it's because both of these squares
actually defend the two threats that uh
that white makes from d5 right white
threatens to step
to c6 the square that corresponds with
c8
and in fact e6 the square that
corresponds with e8
and so from both of these squares black
is actually able
to contest both of these threats
so d8 doesn't correspond with d4 d8
actually corresponds with
d5 so you have this interesting position
where no matter whose turn it is here
the position is actually drawn
right he stepped to d5 so we need to
step to a corresponding square
king d7 is a draw however if we get the
position with the other side to move
king d7 king d5 now king d8
is still a draw and the reason for this
is because
these squares all correspond d5
corresponds to both of these squares
because both of these threats are
defended against
by the black king so you see how this
can start to get a little bit
complex here where did all my pretty
squares go okay
i'll just have to redraw them so you see
how
all of these squares sort of correspond
to each other
squares that are opposition of kings so
i'll say it one more time
so corresponding squares are squares
that are are linked
in some manner so when one king steps
to uh we'll we'll say the word attacking
when the attacking king
steps to a square the corresponding
square or the linked square
is the square that the defending king
has to step to
in order to hold the draw so if white
steps
in this case to d5 we need to step to a
corresponding square with black to hold
the draw
in this case there are actually two on
d7
and d8 no matter which of these squares
black steps to the position is still
drawn
why is it still drawn well we can see by
virtue of corresponding squares
from e6 black needs to step to this to
the linked square
on e8 from c6 black needs to step to the
linked square on c8
and he can achieve this task from either
the d8
square or the d7 square so it doesn't
matter
which one he's on okay
uh let's move on to a little bit
more complex still just one pawn on the
board
but in this case it is actually going to
be black to move
so we have black to move here and to uh
to try and hold the draw and we're gonna
build
this uh using corresponding squares
so this one is still simple enough that
you'd likely be able to solve it just
using sort of calculation
but we're going to try to solve it using
corresponding squares
because then
then we can use this technique to solve
more complex positions
so how can we build our corresponding
squares well
we know that d5 e5 and f5
are all the key squares right the
square's two steps in front of the pawn
we know that
from this position right the three
squares in front of the pawn
so these three squares are our key
squares
then we know that e4 is going to be
linked
to which square it's going to be linked
to e6 right
it makes these three threats e6 defends
these three threats
we also know that f4 is going to be
linked to f6 we saw this in the first
example
it threatens to step to e4 so black
needs to step to e6
it threatens to step to these two
squares so black has to guard all three
squares
meaning king f6 must be playable here
uh now the question is
the white king is on f3 so which square
corresponds to f3 i'm going to try to
ask you guys to do this
without me drawing the circles on the
board for you guys
so just verbally try and visualize these
three key squares
these two squares are linked and these
two squares are linked try to keep that
in your head
for the moment so we have f3 which
squares
correspond to the f3 square
well actually sorry let me start simpler
don't even think about which squares
correspond
which squares is white threatening to
step to
which squares does white threaten to
step to
what is white threatening to do on his
next turn
let me ask you this question first
so chess king try and get away from this
idea of of opposition because it'll only
take you so far
for example g4 g6 that doesn't matter
right
king g4 we just step king e6 and and
it's the same
so he's threatening yes he's threatening
king f4 he's threatening something else
as well
what else is white threatening not only
king f4 but also king e4
right threatening king f4 and king e4
so we know through corresponding squares
which two squares
correspond to f4 and e4 which two
squares does black
need to guard
which squares does black need to guard
if white threatens king f4 and king e4
yes he needs to guard f6 and which other
square
which other square
f6 and e6 that's exactly right
so the black king seems to be placed
very very well
right it already guards e6 and f6
so which move correspond or which
squares correspond to f3
well we know that actually f7 does right
because they guard
uh the same squares but black actually
needs a second square
just to correspond to f3 otherwise he'll
be losing
because he has to move his king it's
black's turn
so which other square corresponds yeah
the chad already has it it's the e7
square
and the reason is it also guards these
two squares
and this is why uh black to move
is still a draw in the position and now
like i said you can probably just
calculate this one out using chess skill
but it's useful to practice this
corresponding squares technique for the
positions we're going to have
a little bit later on this lecture so to
draw
out we have the three key squares here
we have these two squares
which correspond uh these two squares
we'll go red which corresponds and then
f3
threatens to step to e4 which is linked
to e6
and f4 which is linked to f6
so from here from f3
black needs to guard these two squares
you can do
do so from f7 but also from e7
so the corresponding squares to f3 are
f7 and e7 which means black to move is
still a draw
because king e7 is playable in this
position
now no matter which square white steps
to black can step
to the corresponding square king f4 king
f6
if white to move first so that's a good
question billy so let me turn that
question to the chat
if it was white to move in this position
what would be the evaluation
white to move what would be the
evaluation here
as far as what level this lesson is for
well manny i said at the top of the hour
this is actually a really uh interesting
feature of king and pawn in games
where these puzzles end up being more
like logic puzzles
than chess puzzles revolving around
chess techniques so
visualization is definitely going to
help you as a chess skill
but honestly it's it's more something
that i think anybody could learn
given enough enough time and effort
totally drawn why is it drawn not
because of opposition
i mean indirectly because of opposition
yes but because f7
also corresponds to f3 both of these
squares correspond we map this out
with our corresponding squares here so
white could still
threaten to step to e4 or
f4 but black can still step to the two
squares he needs
to be able to guard so king e7 and king
f7
these are both squares that correspond
to f3 in this position
all right does anybody not understand
that right if it were white to move here
let me just triangulate
white to move here still no matter what
white does
black can meet the king on the
corresponding square
so yeah if black plays king of six what
happens that's a great question
so let's map this out one more time for
the sake of showing it
so if black plays king f6
what's the winning idea for white well
you step to the corresponding square
king f4 and now black will lose
because black can no longer stay on the
corresponding square to white he's not
able to step to the square
because he's already on the square isn't
that just distant opposition
well it's the same idea but we'll see in
the next
puzzle we're going to move beyond the
scope of distant opposition
into positions where you have to use
this technique to solve it which is why
we're starting simple
and then moving forward so king f4 would
win the game
if black tries to maintain control of
the key squares by stepping to e6
we can step to the corresponding square
once again and black is unable to remain
on the corresponding square he'll step
away and white will step up to a key
square
and win the game
if the white king started on f4 then uh
depending on whose turn it is white to
move he can step to a key square so of
course white would be winning
black to move black can of course step
to f6 as we were just
talking about okay any other questions
before we move on to the tough stuff
once again i'll draw these out for you
guys
any other questions all right let's
move on to a study this is a study
by a man named nicolet grigoriev way
back
in 1924 and
this is where corresponding squares are
really going to be
more or less the only hope of finding a
solution
so to find the corresponding squares we
first have to understand
where the key squares are so let's try
and map out some key squares
now when i talk about key squares let's
back up for just a moment
i mentioned these three key squares of
course if the white king gets to these
squares
he's like winning winning as well right
you know the white king up here would
also win
same idea pushing the pawn but we only
highlighted these three
because they're the closest to the king
right you can't step to e6 without first
really passing through one of the key
squares already
so we don't need to highlight like all
of these squares because that would
start getting a bit silly
so keep that in mind for this lecture
try to find the key squares closest to
the white king
right so if white steps to this square
then he definitely wins
but you know obviously if you're passing
through other key squares it's not
not really relevant so let's find some
key squares
if white to play king e2 or king f2 is
winning
and sie so that's perfect nikah uh
so e2 and f2 are key squares the first
square you mentioned was e3 but we don't
actually care about this square
because you can't get to e3 without
getting through e2 or f2
first so these are our first two key
squares why are they key squares
well because you can't stop white from
getting to e3
no matter where on the board this king
is and then d4 will follow for example
king f4
white can always play king f2 and invade
or invade and
white will win this pawn and win the
game so no matter what
e2 and f2 are key squares right
similarly if king f2 first nothing black
can do
white gets to e3 and has this idea to
win the game
so through some calculation we see that
both e2
and f2 are key squares
now are there any other key squares on
the board
chess king says yes also a4 b4
a2 i don't know
you'll you'll have to uh to clarify
there chess king i'm not sure exactly
what you mean
d3 well d3 we're not going to count as a
key square because our king can't move
there right
e2 and f or e2 and f2 are our key
squares
so yeah nakat actually has another key
square for us over on
b3 if uh white gets to b3
white always wins the game do we know
this to be true well let's think about
it
white goes king b3 black needs to defend
this pawn
so we'll say king d4 is the only move
then king b4
and obviously white can capture on the
next turn and we'll win the game
right so b3 is definitely a
key square are there any other key
squares
in the position
so key squares are generally for the uh
the attacking side there are some
positions where
both sides have key squares but it's a
little bit outside the scope
of of this lecture we're focusing right
now on on the attacking side
any other key square so yeah chess king
has the last
key square on the board for us he has a3
so
a3 is also a key square and the reason
for this once again
if the white king miraculously lands on
the a3 square
no matter where you put this black king
aside from maybe
absurd positions like c1 uh like c1
yeah then um then white is going to
still
win the game right because you cannot
stop king b3 there's just no way for the
black king to guard this square
and then we know king b3 is already
winning so we have
our four key squares right and these are
going to be pretty much the only key
squares
we have to worry about like we said we
don't care about e3 because you would
have to step to e2 or f2 first to get
there
g2 is not going to be a key square
because the black king
can invade very very quickly and so e2
and f2 are the only key squares on this
side of the board
now obviously if white gets to these
squares he wins as well but you can't
get there without crossing here first so
all of that is to say we have these key
squares
figured out uh what's different about
this position compared to the simple
positions we were looking at before
well of course the difference here is
that the key squares
are separated uh what this means
is that it becomes a lot more complex to
figure out
which squares correspond with each other
because from e1
let me highlight this square white
threatens to go to f2
into e2 but it's a little unclear how
this
king is relating to these key squares on
the queen side
so we have to sort of figure this idea
out as well
so king e1 has two threats on the king's
side to step to king e2 or king f2
so obviously these two are key squares
black would have to step here or here
if he wants to draw of course the
position is in fact black to move
um but it's actually making
another threat as well it's threatening
to step to d1
and to start interacting with these
squares
on the queen side as well and so this is
where it's going to get a little bit
hairy
so let's nakat is
saying this position is completely
winning for white
you would be wrong because it is black
to move and
draw this position
okay if black moves it's a draw nikon
has rescinded his opinion all right
i love it and he says king e3 is the
draw we'll see
it's either king e3 or king f3 has to be
one of those right
so we have king on e1 threatening yes
to go to the kingside key squares but
also also the queen side key squares as
well right
so let's first talk about
the a2 square i want to start over here
because i do think
it is a bit simpler it will give us more
information
so from a2 white threatens to step to b3
and a3 now of course these are the only
two squares on the board where black can
contest
these threats uh but let's look what's
the other threat the threat is to step
one two three four and in
four moves white will be able to step to
e2
so black actually needs a square
that can get to e2 in as short
of time so let's imagine if the king
starts on a4
further away we have king b1 king b4
king c1 king c5 king d1
king d4 and white gets to e2 right
so we can go ahead and eliminate a4
because
we see that even though this key square
is far away
it still matters how fast the king can
arrive
so these two are our first corresponding
squares now let's try and build
closer and closer to the
king side let's start with b1 now
let's start with b1 uh
who in the chat can tell me the
corresponding square
to b1 who can tell me
who knows who's got the know-how
chess king says b5
any other ideas nikot says c5
chess king says d5 he means c5 though
schlock says he can tell me but doesn't
tell me which one
manny says c5 so yeah you guys are right
it's king c5
and this is the only one sorry let me
adjust my color the reason is
threatens to step to this blue square of
course
we know that you know in chess we don't
actually have blue squares
but this is signifying that this square
is linked to a2
from b1 white threatens to step to a2 so
black also needs to threaten a step to
b4 because we know these squares
are linked white also threatens to
get to e2 in three short moves so we
need
two moves to uh to guard this square as
well so black can match white over here
okay so we have b1 and c5
it's getting easier and easier now to
build towards
the king side what happens on king c1
yeah manny see this is uh this is a
really fun and interesting part
of of chess that a lot of people have
never heard about
and honestly i'm gonna level with you
guys this may not have
the most practical application
applications you can probably go a long
time in your chest career without
ever using this idea over the board but
i do think it's a very very fun
logic puzzle and everyone in the chat is
telling me that d4 is the square and
that's exactly right
so similarly what square corresponds
with d1
we know it's e3 so
with this information in mind black to
move
and draw what do you guys think
black to move and draw
black to move and draw what do you guys
think
the chat is splits manny the politician
says either king f3 or king e3
all right dude so there's a person in
the chat that says you can call me dude
so dude if you're not understanding
what's going on
i highly encourage you to watch the
first part of this lecture as well
because we started very very basic
and then built up from there nakat and
now in all caps is saying not king f3
not king f3
just king e3 but in fact of course
from e1 white is making three threats
and it's very easy to see what three
threats he's making now
he threatens to step to e2 a key square
f2 a key square and he also threatens to
step
to d1 so we know that in order to draw
black must step to a square that can
guard
e2 f2 and the square that is linked
to d1 and we know now that d1 is
linked or corresponds to the e3 square
so there's only one square on the board
that achieves all three of these tasks
and that square is f3 so king f3
is the only move that draws in this
position
so let's try and understand it without
the circles now
we see king f3 is the only move that
draws
so if white steps to d1 we step to the
square that corresponds to d1
what corresponds to d1 well we know we
need a square
that can come to guard the queen side
and also still guards
e2 and that square is e3
now if king c1 we know we need to step
to the corresponding square
where we can get to the queen site in
time but no
not stray too far from the king's side
and that's d4
if king b1 then of course we have to
step to c5
now i want to ask you guys a very
important question
you thought the puzzle was over you
thought the puzzle was over
but what happens if white plays the move
king a1
black to move here c if you fully
understand
the corresponding squares that we mapped
out earlier
so we mapped out a bunch of
corresponding squares i left a1
blank though because i want to ask you
guys this question here
so from a1 you know that white threatens
to step
to two squares and you know which
squares are linked
to those squares so you can then figure
out which square black has to step to
and yeah you guys
are really getting it here wow i'm i'm
i'm actually very impressed
you guys are right on top of this one of
course it has to be
king b5 no other move will draw after
king a1
king b4 of course is not going to do it
the reason being after king a2 king a4
to guard the squares white can run back
to the king's side in time
and we can very very simply understand
this
by realizing these are white's two
threats these are the two squares that
correspond with those two squares
the only space for black to move to is
b5
to guard these two squares so king a1
king b5
is very important what if black went to
d2
uh
okay in this king a1 line let's take a
look
if black goes this way he is
unfortunately a little bit too slow
right a little bit too slow here
so the black king has to defend all the
key squares to draw
so yes but not only does he have to
defend them immediately
he has to make sure he can always defend
them in the future which is where these
corresponding squares come into play
right because we see that if i can do
this
one more time for you guys king a1 king
b4 regarding these key squares
is not enough because he's not on the
corresponding square
to a2 so now white can run to the other
key squares
okay so what happens if black plays king
e3 first you probably should be asking
yourself
and the issue now is that we know that
e3 corresponds to d1
so after white plays king d1 black would
love to play king e3 but now he can't
which means this king has to pick one
side over the other
either d4 or f3 if king f3
guarding this square we see that black
is simply not in top not in time excuse
me
uh and if king d2 once again
it's just just d4 if king d4
of course then king e2 and this this one
is even simpler
so king e3 does not draw the game king
f3 does
and whenever white plays king a1 black
must play the move
king b5 uh very interesting to see how
these squares become
less and less uh logically linked or
intuitively linked
well they are logically linked less
intuitively linked but
we can still map out these these deeper
connections
so black to move king f3 draws the game
king d1 black can always meet him king
e1
of course king f3 and if white tries
funny business like this
we always can step to the corresponding
square
no matter what white tries
not king c5 which would lose the game
but king b5
keeping both of these options open of
course king c5
would mean king b1 gets played and now
black again would have to choose sides
if you go here
i step in if you go king b5 or king b4
i can step this way okay
any questions on this puzzle right
because this was
the first one where we separated the key
squares
and the first one where we separated the
key squares
opposition is just a small part of
corresponding squares
so yes manny yes this is why in the
beginning when it was very very simple
uh with end games we all knew i was
encouraging you guys to try and think
about it
using corresponding squares and not
opposition because opposition takes you
only so far
all right if everybody's on board
we're getting crazy we're getting crazy
now we're getting absolutely crazy
um the kings are very very far apart and
we're gonna have to work very very hard
to draw all of the corresponding squares
in
this position but i believe in us
i believe in our ability to do it so
let's figure it out kiloton quits
yeah yeah so this one you know everybody
loves a good black to move and draw a
puzzle
but who doesn't love a good white to
move and win
puzzles so that's what we have on our
hands here
so what's the first step the first step
of course is to draw out the key squares
so who in the chat can tell me
what the key squares are in this
position
who has the key squares here
who has the key squares which squares
uh does white win if he he arrives at
a2 no these squares don't do anything
these squares don't do anything
we need a square where when the white
king lands on that square we declare
victory and our opponent resigns
so c7 e7 f4 h4
so we're getting somewhere now we're
arriving i think everybody can agree
that king f4 is a key square the white
king lands
on f4 no matter where the black king is
white is going to win right if the black
king's in h5
king f5 is playable and then we just
take this guy right
so f4 i'm willing to put on the board h4
isn't so much a key square for the same
reason as those other
uh squares like e3 in the previous
puzzle you simply can't get
to h4 without first crossing through f4
right you can't get it from this side of
the board there's just not enough room
on the chessboard
if you could play king i3 then maybe you
could get there but you can't
so it's not a key square king e3 is not
very clearly a key square
because you can imagine that from e3 you
threaten to step to a key square
but black can sufficiently stop you with
king g5
and there's no easy way to just barge
your way onto that square so
f4 is a key square h4 is not
c7 and e7 unfortunately these squares
aren't very realistic
because if you ever get king c7 black is
likely going to be able
to to capture these pawns and so i'll
give you a hint here there's actually
only
one more key square on the board
but it's not a very intuitive one you
probably
wouldn't be able to find this on your
own without some hint from me
so that's your hint you wouldn't be able
to find it unless i gave you a hint
d4 so d4 is not really a key square
right king f6 would still contest this
king
king i3 king i3 might be a key square
but i
it's not on the board unfortunately um
okay i'll give it to you
so unfortunately these plans of going
this way are
are just too slow uh they're just too
slow
i'll just tell you this tell you this
now uh also
actually let's say you even get over
there right
let's say you get over there
say black gives you infinite time to get
over there i i don't think you're even
winning
right king e7
i don't think you even win if you get
there
okay so back to the starting position so
those aren't the key squares
in fact the final key square is actually
e5
uh and you might be thinking well how
does that make any
sense at all well the reason is uh we
wouldn't threaten to play
king e5 but we would actually threaten
to play pawn
e5 so if you imagine
a position where i'll just show you you
don't have to imagine
where our king is on d4 now if the pawn
didn't control this square we would play
king e5 and one win the game
but fortunately for black the pawn does
however
e5 is a playable move here and no matter
where the king is
i'll put him on a slightly better square
e7
no matter where the king is it doesn't
matter this is now going to be winning
for white and to prove it to you
i will capture this pawn in glorious
fashion
wait no i won't hold on made it hard on
myself
we'll box the king out and then capture
this pawn in glorious fashion
and promote to victory right
so that makes f4 and e5 the key squares
now
let's start picking out some
corresponding squares
so who knows where we should start with
building these these corresponding
squares where should we start
so kiloton the difference is
you know you can say the same thing for
f4 right you can only get there via e3
the difference is if we achieve e5
or if you imagine if we achieved
uh soul control of e5 that's that's kind
of the thing let's start with f4
and then use f4 to understand e5 so if
we achieve
sole control of f4 then we get to play
king f4
and then we win the game right if we
play king f4 we win the game
if we play king e3 we don't win the game
because black can step
to g5 to box this out right to contest
our control
so similarly if we play king d4 this
isn't a key square
because the black king can step to f6 to
contest our control over e5 and then we
wouldn't win we don't win if this
happens
this is a losing attempt in fact a very
good one
i think it is a successful losing
attempt
so e5 and f4 are the only key squares
so yeah people are throwing out some
squares now i'm kind of giving it away
with my explanations here
but yeah d4 and f6 are key squares or
corresponding squares
excuse me corresponding squares
uh and of course e3 and g5
are corresponding squares because
whenever we step to d4
black needs to contest our control of e5
and whenever we step to e3
black needs contrast to contest our
control of
f4 otherwise we'll play pawnee five and
win or king f4 and win
so these are the simplest squares
to to draw out right these are sort of
the easy
ones these are the freebies uh
now let's try and build out even further
our idea of corresponding squares can we
do it
can we build out even further here
who sees another set of corresponding
squares
so great wolf asks how do you know if
you're building the corresponding
squares correctly it seems a little
confusing when starting out with this
technique
well the key is to make sure you
understand what the key squares are
so that's why we spent time at the
beginning of the puzzle here
to make sure we understood which squares
were definitely winning
for white and we know that f4 is
definitely winning for white
and e5 is definitely winning for white
and how do you uncover those
well you look for the squares where you
can say okay
if my king lands here it doesn't matter
where
on the board at least within reason the
enemy king
is white is always going to be winning
right
you put this king on f4 it doesn't
matter where on the board
uh the black king is h5 over here on e7
over here on g6
we're gonna take this pawn and win the
game it's unstoppable
same thing with playing the move e5 if
we have
the ability to play e5 then no matter
where on the board the king is
right no matter where on the board it is
if we can play e5 then we win the game
so you start with the key squares and
then you ask yourself
to you build out from those key squares
just
geometrically right start close to the
key squares
from d4 white threatens control of the
key square
and there's only one square on the board
for black that can contest
this control and that square is f6 same
thing with e3 he has to contest control
of f4
otherwise white steps to it and so you
have g5
and as far as how can you be sure well
you just have to you have to think it
through right
you ask yourself is there any other
square on the board in the area where if
i play king e3
black can also go to this square to stop
me from reaching the key square
and now we can start building out
now we can start building out okay
so um i'm going to go with
victor because that's the one part of
that name that i can pronounce
or maybe victor is saying e4
and g6 are corresponding squares and
apologies if someone else has already
said this
oh i sorry the square is d3 d3 and g6
which manny is saying other people are
saying
got my coordinates confused so d3 and g6
how do we arrive at these two squares
being corresponding well
we see that from d3 white makes two
threats
great wolf says what if the pawn
structure changes does that affect the
corresponding squares so the positions
we're looking at are positions in which
the pawn structure can't
can't really change um
so in this case we're using e5
as a substitute for king e5 to as
the way we win using control of the key
square
all right so how do we know that d3
corresponds with g6 well you look at
what white is threatening
from d3 so how did we actually get to
the square on d3 in the first place
well like the key squares now we want to
build out further
towards our king so we can start to
understand what our winning attempt
might be
and so where does it make sense to build
from using these two squares
well you want to build from the square
that looks the most threatening right
and so these two squares can both be
attacked from d3
which is why we're looking at this
square first so from d3
white threatens both king d4 which
threatens the key square e5
and king e3 which threatens the key
square at 4.
so black needs a similar square in his
camp
to contest these squares as well and
that the only square for black
to guard the two squares that are linked
we know that d4
connects with f6 and e3 connects with g5
so black needs to defend these two
squares and can do so
from g6 you can't color the squares yeah
that's why i tried to get you guys on
the previous puzzle the slightly simpler
one
to be able to do it without all the
funny colors but we'll look at it here
we'll look at it here
uh and now we want to build out from
here and this is where it does end up
being a little bit tricky
as well so where do we want to build
next i think dj mitchell has the right
idea we want to look
at the square of c3 i'm
gonna go back to green here because i'm
having a severe shortage
of colors i'm gonna go back to c3 and
the reason for this
is because it's a pretty threatening
move
it threatens to step to these two
squares and it's also the closest square
our king can
get to so it's useful to to sort of pick
this one out first
um in general i think in dvoretsky's
endgame manual
he also recommends this sort of
technique for building corresponding
squares which revolves around
completing the square uh a different
kind of square
and not completing the square that you
learned in algebra class
a different kind as well a third kind of
completing completing the square
so we're going to look at c3 here
so c3 makes a few threats it threatens
to step
to d4 and it threatens to step to
d3 right so which squares on the board
uh can test this for black well
uh offhand it looks like both f7
and g7 work as well both
f7 and g7 would defend these two squares
right
offhand and the problem is white is
actually making
a third threat to keep track of and
that's the tricky bit
when you're building out uh a square in
this manner
from this little starting uh triangle
that we have here
you want to complete this square around
the triangle
and this is where it gets tricky when
you build it out because when you
build the c3 square you not only have to
consider these two threats
but you have to consider if white can
interact with
the other corresponding or key squares
in any other manner
and in fact he can so not only is he
threatening to step
to d4 he's also threatening step to d3
which we know
but he's actually also threatening to
step to d2
now why does d2 have unique value
from d3 and d4 well because
it's threatening to step to a different
combination
of corresponding squares i'm going to
say that again it threatens to step
to a different set or different
combination
of corresponding squares what do i mean
by that
well i mean that from d2
white threatens to step to a blue square
a yellow square and back to c3 right
for the moment though we're going to
focus on the blue square and the yellow
square so it threatens to step
to e3 which links to g5 and it threatens
to step
to d3 which links to g6 so we know
that these are actually three threats
the white king is making
from c3 so
from f7 it's true that black would guard
these two corresponding squares
it can uh match king d4 with king f6 and
king d3 with king g6
but it can't actually match king d2
because it doesn't have any way to get
to a square
from f7 that guards both a yellow
and a blue square right it doesn't it's
not able
to contest the threats that are made by
king d2 king d2 threatens king e3
so we need king g5 and king d3 so we
would need
king g6 that's why
we can build these two squares sort of
at the same time here that's the only
way it really works
so we see now that g7 is linked to c3
because it also
can step to the h6 square which is
linked to d2
right so i kind of skipped a step there
so let me change colors here
from c3 white makes all three of these
threats
so black needs to court to uh respond
to all three of these threats in kind
from d2 it threatens this
e3 square so g5 and d3 square
so g6 so we need to be able to play king
h6
in response to guard both of these
squares as
well alright so that got a little bit
crazy
a little bit crazy there but hopefully
you guys
all followed now
why doesn't f7 still work why can't we
step
to king f6 after the move king d2
well let's put it on the board and see
if we can intuitively
figure it out so we're looking for king
f7
and then why doesn't king f6 uh work
in response to uh
king to d2 why doesn't this work
because it seems like e3 corresponds
with g5
d3 corresponds with g6 c3 corresponds
with uh
in this case we're arguing f7 or g7
so why doesn't f6 work
king d3 we know the corresponding square
for king d3 it's king g6 and black has
achieved the draw
he stepped to the corresponding square
in fact the problem is actually e2
right so let's back up here
oh god it took away
my beautiful all right speed drawing
time
try and do the same colors
uh we're looking at these squares and i
made this one
red okay so
why doesn't king f6 work with d2 well
because king e2
also threatens to step to yellow and
blue and there's no square for black
from
f6 where he can also step to yellow and
blue
so you kind of have to build these out
together so
e2 if i can find the color
green we'll go with threatens the step
to both yellow and blue
and back to d2 which threatens to step
to c3 d3
and e3 trying to do this with uh without
saying the colors and i'm noticing i'm
out of time
as we're posting in the chat room that
var is up next
so i will try to go through this quickly
now
so for that reason h6 is the only square
that corresponds to
d2 which means g7 is the only square
that corresponds to c3 because we need
to be able to step here
and from e2 uh we can match this with
king h5
so from this we can build out further
now just intuitively
c2 and h7 c4 and f7
and now we just need to go one or two
steps further
so from
b2 what's going on from b2 i'll make it
red
we're threatening to step to c3 aka g7
and we're threatening to step to c2 aka
h7 we're also threatening to step to c1
which threatens blue c2 so
h7 and d2 so h6
and to step back to b2 which we're
saying corresponds now
with h8 because it defends both of these
squares so from c1
we can intuitively make this out to
correspond
actually back to g7 because it defends
all the same squares the same threats
that white is making here
see how these threats and these threats
are actually identical
despite looking very very different so
to answer the question of why king b2
doesn't win the game
it's because king h8 steps to the
corresponding square
and then white is unable to make the
threats
so the final question for you guys is
what square
corresponds to b1 and i'm not going to
have to i'm not going to have time
to give the live chat time to think
about this if you want to figure it out
for yourself
what corresponds to b1 pause the video
now
if you don't want it the answer
of course is it corresponds to g8
b1 threatens the step to b2 which
corresponds to h8 threatens the step to
c2 which corresponds to h7
and threatens the step to c1 which
corresponds to g7
the only square that can do that for
black is g8
so of course the way to win this
position is to play king b1
because black cannot step to the
corresponding square since he's already
on it so king b1 wins the game
then we simply step to the corresponding
square that black cannot reach
so if he steps to h8 he can no longer
step to h8 after king b2 if he steps to
king g7
we know that king c3 corresponds with g7
he steps to f6 then it's very easy if he
steps to f7
we know that f7 corresponds to uh what
does f7 correspond to
king of c4 okay
we're building it here we're building it
here wait a second king b1
we know that f7 corresponds to king c4
and if king
will wait a second hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on
trying to go too fast this is tricky
enough that you kind of have to take
your time
all right
okay all right king b1 king h8 right
we know that he steps to f7 he can no
longer step
to the square that corresponds to d2
because d2 corresponds with h6
so now we win the game by stepping to
this square black
cannot meet us if he steps king g6 we
know that king d3
corresponds with king g6 and now he has
to choose
white has the choice between these two
squares to gain control of the key
squares black can only defend one
and whites will get to sorry white will
will meet him there on the corresponding
square black will have to leave
and then white will win the game by
invading on the key square
so that was a lot to go over there at
the end it was very very complicated
i want to leave you guys with one more
thing to think about
this i think is the most complicated
corresponding squares puzzle
that i found so if you guys want a real
challenge this is a
study by lasker and reichel back in
1901.
if you guys can solve this using
corresponding squares your true
masters and lastly i do want to mention
this was
this position is a study by charles
dealtry lockup back in 1982
hopefully you guys gained an
understanding of corresponding squares
if you don't fully understand this last
position uh
fully that's okay it's a really really
complicated idea to expand these
corresponding squares out
but i think it's a really fun unique uh
interesting type
of puzzle that exists within the rules
of chess that many people don't know
about
hopefully you enjoyed this lecture
please stay tuned for grand master
varukovians lecture
straight after this on the same youtube
channel i believe we've posted a link in
the chat
hopefully you enjoyed